happening right now some ccsd educators
are participating in a walkout over a
potential vaccine mandate 8 news now
reporter kate houston is live with the
group and has the latest
yes well that group grew to more than
100 people close to 200 really but since
they have been pretty spread out here on
the strip many have been waving flags
and holding signs on this pedestrian
overpass many though are no longer here
ccsd says 813 employees use sick leave
today which is less than 5 percent but
about double the amount on an average
day
the group that coordinated this rally is
las vegas freedom of choice they say
they're not for or against masks and
vaccinations but want people to have a
say in these decisions this picked up
momentum after the school board allowed
superintendent jara to create a vaccine
mandate for all employees the staff
members taking part in today's walkout
want to show the school district the
impact it would have if they weren't
there briana is a teacher within the
school district she asked us to blur her
image over concerns for her job i think
it really put things into perspective i
do know that a lot of bus drivers called
up today the
students were waiting outside for a
really long time even i was getting
phone calls because i know you know as
guilty as it made me feel i know we
needed to let them know that this is
what it would really look like if they
were to force something like that on us
she says many parents are in support of
las vegas freedom of choice they're also
worried that a staff vaccine mandate
could lead to one for students
we'll back out here live that rally
ended at six o'clock so just a few
minutes ago we still have some people
walking around with their flags and
signs but i also reached out to the
school district for an update on the
vaccine mandate and i am waiting for
their response reporting live near the
aria kate houston 8 news now